in the mid 1980s dr cars theorized the
definition of the two these two type of
games finite games and infinite games a
finite game is defined as known players
fixed rules and an agreed upon objective
football baseball there's always a
beginning middle and an end and if
there's a winner then necessarily there
has to be a loser
then there are infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players which means new players can join
at any time
the rules are changeable which means
everyone can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible
turns out we're players in infinite
games every day of our lives whether we
know it or not
there's no such thing as winning global
politics there's no such thing as
winning education right you can come in
first for the finite amount of time
you're at school we haven't where we
have an agreed upon time frame the
school year and we've agreed upon
metrics grades but nobody wins education
nobody's declared the winner of careers
and there's definitely no such thing as
winning business
no one no one no one's declared the
winner of business
but if you listen to the language of so
many leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't actually know the game
they're playing in they talk about being
number one or being the best or beating
their competition
based on what
based upon what agreed upon metrics
objectives or time frames
and this is a problem because when we
play with a finite mindset in an
infinite game when we play to win or be
the best in a game that has no finish
line
there are some predictable and
consistent outcomes
the big ones include the decline of
trust the decline of cooperation and the
decline of innovation
and so we have to learn to play for the
game that we are in if you're playing a
game of baseball show up with a finite
mindset play to win
if you have a new client
right that you're trying to pitch or
there is a winning there's a beginning
middle and end and when the client makes
the decision to choose you or choose
your choose somebody else then that game
has concluded but if you win the client
if you gain a new client now you have to
convert now it's about the infinite game
there's no winning anymore
now it's about making sure that the
client is happy and that they stay in
the game with you for as long as
possible
and we have to adjust our mindset to
play for the game that we're in and
unfortunately a lot of business leaders
do not play for the game that they're in